there will be a time be a time that you
see the light see the light CEO is a
simple message but one that has captured
the imagination of women around the
world
[Music]
I was in my early 20s I was part of a
pop group called Paradiso girls and when
I was in the group at the time I was
having an amazing time but looking back
I realized I got told what to wear I got
told what to sing I got told how to act
and I think this time around I wanted to
do something that was not only my voice
but I'd something that would speak to
other women that would be relatable
[Music]
Kelly's mission to reach women in places
like Pakistan Bangladesh Iran and India
where content is often blocked has been
hugely challenging well they've gone to
enormous lengths to try and distribute
this in a way that it's not crackable so
that someone using for instance
blockchain technology or the lantern
technology which they've used can access
the video and therefore circumvent the
government blocking of the video
[Music]
to get women's from places like
Afghanistan from Kenya from Mexico
they're all saying I'm from Mexico I am
she
I am from Kenya I am she I was just like
I achieved what I set out to achieve
that there's this is the connection to
women and there's a connection that
together we we have this like inner
power and I think the patriarchy
sometimes doesn't realize that we are
worried as to and just to have so many
women saying this has affected me so
much honestly well I cried Kellie's now
hoping her track will become an anthem
for women who feel silenced or ignored
everywhere Lucy Carter Sky News